zamierzamy przeprowadzić operację w Czernihowie
zbawienie ludzi zbawienie chorych zbawienie
ranny
Ty, który teraz musisz zabrać do Kijowa
o dodatkową pomoc
właściwie utworzyliśmy tę podróż po
jako wolontariusze Wiaczesław
Zaporożec, zorganizowali grupę jaków
wyprowadził ludzi, którzy byli z okolicznych miast
potrzebna tam pilna opieka
gdzieś tam znowu coś się urwało
Moja matka trafiła do szpitala, ponieważ
obok naszego mieszkania w
W Czernihowie wybuchła potężna bomba
w pierwszej chwili mówi taka ciepła fala
który ją odrzucił A potem druga fala
przyszedł i całkowicie zerwał tam jej sufit
uderzenie odłamkiem i mama trafiła do szpitala
ale miała tam operację oka
konieczne było wykonanie innej operacji
już nie mogli zrobić A ten jest otoczony
zbombardowany i tak dalej I już dzwoniłem
do naczelnego lekarza i tam mówię chodźmy
Mówię, wyrzućmy to jakoś
zróbmy pierwszą rzecz, popatrzymy z dronami, aby
nie było żadnych narkotyków ani w ogóle
sił zbrojnych Federacji Rosyjskiej
chciałem poznać te miejsca, w których istnieje niebezpieczeństwo
ponieważ są pola, na których A otoczone jest lasem i
dostosowują drony i czołg gaśnie
Bach pokrył pole i wrócił i to wszystko
Chodzi o to, Wiaczesław, wolontariusz, tak, powiedział, że
te rzeczy muszą być niebezpieczne
pojechaliśmy do Czernihowa rzucić okiem
w końcu to znaczy, że zostało odebrane
ciężko chorych zabierała tam babcia, która już była
tam z problemem nogi, to znaczy, że ją zabrali
tylko siedzące mogły, bo tylko dwie
samochód przyjechał, trzeba było wracać
Więc zostali zabrani ze szpitala wojewódzkiego do
podkręcenie jest normalne lub mocniejsze
zdecydowanie wyglądaj trochę więcej
wszystko jest dobrze wszystko
Powodzenia
wyszliśmy i kontynuowali. No cóż, już
widzieliśmy bezpieczną trasę, a oni
potem kontynuowali wyjmowanie tego, co było tutaj w
niektóre samochody miały po jednym chodziku, a potem
opuścili teraz karawanę z Kulikówki
już jest bezpiecznie, ale potem było w porządku
trochę więc co?
bardzo ważne, gdy planowana jest pomoc humanitarna
misją jest zrozumienie, gdzie to jest
przeciwnik, z którym się zgodziłeś lub nie
zgodził się, ponieważ widzimy, że Rosja nie jest
wywiązuje się z podjętych zobowiązań
dla siebie i dla cywilów bez słowa
już tam o wojsku tam na zakończenie
ognia To znaczy, nie chodzi o nic i dlatego, kiedy ty
zgadzasz się z takimi
przeciwnik, wróg wszelkiego rodzaju
wypełnia zobowiązania przyjęte przez
zapewnienie bezpiecznego przejścia
ludność cywilna tego potrzebuje
kontrolować, kontrolować co może
W tym celu może pomóc dron
innego typu, jeśli nie ma takiej możliwości
konieczne jest unieszkodliwianie odpadów
aby odnotować, że jestem w niebezpieczeństwie, jeśli zniknie
cywilny korytarz i musi być głośno
jeśli uzgodniono lub milcząco
utrzymaj ten korytarz i
Kontroluj te miejsca, nie daj Boże
istnieje pewne niebezpieczeństwo, żebyśmy mogli szybko
pochyl się do przodu i zobacz to niebezpieczeństwo
Myślę, że pozwoli to ratować ludzkie życie
którzy chodzą tym uzgodnionym korytarzem?
czy nie zgodził się, to nadal to
ważniejsze, ale żeby ich używać
drony muszą zrozumieć, że możemy je
stracić i uzupełnić te drony
produkcja tych dronów na zakup tych
Drony wymagają stałych funduszy, ponieważ
park wymaga odnowienia, straty trwają
awarie
kilka błędów itd. Dlatego
niezbędne do zachowania życia cywila
ludność i wojsko jednoznacznie
Rosjanie całkiem dobrze używają dronów
używaj dronów, czyli oddaj to
właściwa jest potrzebna nie od razu
nie musisz angażować się w casting
żeby tam były mięso armatnie i tak dalej
to naprawdę jest, ale ci, którzy
zajmuje się i znam na Białorusi
informacje to wszystko, co teraz mają
jeśli chodzi o Drony, są bardzo mocne
są finansowane i dlatego drony są bardzo ważne
ważne dla ratowania życia żołnierzy i
ludność cywilna
[muzyka]
Apeluję do każdego, kogo to obchodzi
wsparcie zakupów i produkcji
Drony cywilne i wojskowe dla
szczegóły, które zostaną określone na końcu
wideo lub w komentarzach po wideo
Dziękuję Ci